what do you think about rapport's uh
play
that is in the top 10 practically for
quite some time
it's very hard for me to judge
because um
he plays very well against everybody and
then he plays really poorly against me
uh so that makes it
hard for me to be completely unbiased
um
but i think when he's on form he
deserves to be
a top 10 player and
certainly there is room for him to to
improve him even further
and
i think his
understanding of the game is just superb
really
does he only have the image that he goes
to very strange
decisions and creative ideas
is it already the image only or you
still see him doing
he he does it but a little bit less than
he he used to but he's clearly better
prepared than he used to be he has
all of these strange lines that he plays
he studied them he's even going for some
main lines and i've always said in his
career that
he's always been
very good positionally he's been good at
end games
and and i know and all of this and
playing all these weird lines was i
think partly just a matter of
uh matter of taste and also because it
didn't didn't
um
[Music]
it probably didn't work work hard enough
to play play the main lines but
yeah in terms of his his understanding
and his talent there are very few
players who are
are superior
do you think he doesn't like to play
chess or the stress of it or is it also
an image thing that
people have been pushing we included
i'm not so sure um
i think he likes playing chess i'm not
sure as yeah i'm not sure he likes
everything around it but
then again who does
love it